counting sheep when you're trying to  sleep being there's something to say  [Music]  recipe book  how much money you  [Music]  if it's new on the room then what time  is it here if I can't count the right  yeah would you get to infinity or  somewhere in that vicinity  when you choose how much postage to eat  listen what's the chances so when you  pack and your end up in to try just  can't get away from nothing man  and you've also to smile such as they of  all I agree  [Music]  the song while you're singing alone  [Music]  [Applause]  and that my friends is mathematics  spring is here ah suffering is here  life is skittles and life is beer  I think the loveliest time of the year  is the spring I do don't you  course you do  [Music]